[Music]
denisha's in austin texas hi denisha how
are you
hello
denisha hi
how are you hi i am fine how are you
better than i deserve what's up
okay so i have a little
situation um
anytime somebody starts a call with okay
and have a situation it's gonna be great
go for it
okay so
i
uh just um
i have a lot of credit card debt a lot
of it
and i'm in this i'm in school and i just
got a new job very very proud of my job
because
uh going to school for accounting i've
been presented a lot of opportunities
and it's been really great for me so i'm
pretty happy what are you calling about
you didn't call about that
i'm sorry i didn't talk about that
you're avoiding
my
my spouse is very upset with me why
would you i just got my tax
i just got my tax return and i paid off
all the credit cards
and why is he upset that you're
debt-free
because
we're broke
and he
said hey we can just pay the minimums so
why in the world would you just pay the
pay the whole thing that way because we
don't have a lot of money so he's like
you just use all of our tax return to
pay all the credit card debt
okay
how long you guys been married
uh seven years how old are you
thirty okay does he work
he's disabled he's fully disabled okay
what's the nature of his disability
uh bilateral apg
okay
wow all right
so he has disability income is all he
has coming in yesterday okay all right
so the problem is not that you paid off
the credit card debt or that you didn't
pay off the credit card debt the problem
is is that the two of you are not
working together
yes sir
and so you should never he should never
be surprised by a money move you make
because you should have both decided the
money moved together you actually did
the right thing in the wrong way
yes sir
that makes sense
it does make sense so his his opinion is
wrong his anger is right
yes sir that makes sense
yes sir why'd you feel like he had to go
behind his back
did you know what he was gonna say
i knew he was gonna say that at least
shouldn't have done it because he said
we can just pay the minimums that's all
they asked for and i said
but we're trying to get a house we're in
my dad's house he wants us out
not because he doesn't like us here but
he's because he wants you to be
self-sustaining and have dignity
correct so we're trying to get us to
that point
and so
that's why
it's hard huh
marriage is hard
y'all struggling
we're really stressed
i'm so sorry we have a disabled child
who is in and out of the hospital as
well
so
she's
our blessing but she's it's just hard
in that way too so so i've walked i've
walked alongside folks in your situation
tell me if i'm if i'm on the money or if
i'm missing the boat here
that in many ways you are both a wife
and a mother you run the household
except when
um
your disabled husband leans up and says
well i want to be a part of this
decision so you're responsible for
everything you need to be out running
and doing everything
except when i want to weigh in is that
is that fair
that's absolutely correct so you carry
everything
including the quote-unquote bad
decisions that you made on your own
which are supposed to be right so here's
what i really want you to do would your
husband go talk to a marriage counselor
with you
i don't know i don't know if he thinks
that we having a problem
okay that tells me that you're not being
honest with him and i know that i don't
want to dump it all on you because you
may not be safe to be honest but you got
to because here's what i'm afraid it's
going to happen you're going to get a
new job and you're going to make great
money and you're going to go meet
co-workers who are going to light you up
they're going to love you and they're
going to fill gaps in your relationships
in relation to needs that you have
that your husband hasn't been doing or
that y'all have gotten so far apart and
what's gonna happen is you're gonna make
some
you're gonna what you just did going
behind his back is gonna get worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse
so i want you to find a place where we
can start having open and direct
conversations because like dave said you
did the right thing with the money you
did it the wrong way and i don't want
this to you to look up five years from
now and your family's falling apart yeah
his opinion was wrong
but his right to be in on the decision
was right yeah so the two of you need to
start making all the decisions together
all the time
and you need some practice at that you
don't have the muscles to do that so you
need to get with a good marriage
counselor to help you develop that
and yeah you do have a problem
you have a lot of problems and you need
to work on them get right in the middle